my dad had to actually go to chernobyl
with a bunch of
20 year olds he was 20 when he went to
chernobyl
and that was right after the explosion
no one knew anything the whole crew he
went with
all of them are dead now i think there
was this one guy uh still
loud that was still alive for his last
few years i think he died a few years
ago now
my dad somehow luckily got back earlier
than everyone else
but just the fact that that was the and
i was always like well how did they send
you i was only i was just born you know
you had a newborn
talk about paternity leave they were
like but that's who they took because
they didn't know whether you would be
able to have kids when you come back
so they took the ones with kids so him
with some guys want to
and i'm just thinking of me and when i
was 20 i was so
uh sheltered from any problems
whatsoever in life and then my dad
um his 21st birthday
at the reactor you like
work three hours a day you sleep the
rest and and i
yeah so i played with a lot of toys from
chernobyl
what are your memories of chernobyl in
in general like
a bigger context you know because of
that hbo show
it's the world's attention turned to it
once again
like what are your thoughts about
chernobyl did russia screw that one up
like you know there's probably a lot of
lessons about our modern
times with data about coronavirus and
all that kind of stuff
it seems like there's a lot of
misinformation there's a lot of
people kind of trying to hide whether
they've screwed something up or not
as it's very understandable it's very
human very wrong probably
but obviously russia was probably trying
to hide
that they've screwed things up
like what are your thoughts about that
time personal and
in general i mean i was born when
the explosion happened so actually a few
months after so
of course i don't remember anything
apart from the fact that my dad would
bring me tiny
toys be like plastic things that would
just go crazy haywire when you
you know put the gagger thing into it
my mom was like just nuclear about that
um she was like what are you bringing
you should not do that uh
she was nuclear very nice absolutely i'm
sorry
well uh but yeah but the tv show was
just
phenomenal i mean yeah it's definitely
first of all it's an incredible how um
that was made not by the russians
but someone else but capturing so well
everything about the you know about our
country
um it felt a lot more genuine that most
of the movies and tv shows that are made
now in russia just so much more genuine
and most of my friends in russia were
just in complete awe about the
with the show but i think that how good
of a job they did oh my god phenomenal
but all the apartments there's something
yeah the set design i mean russians
can't do that
we you know but you you see everything
and it's like wow that's exactly how it
was
that's so i don't know that show
i don't know what to think about that
because it's british accents
british actors of a person
i forgot who created this show i'm not
but i remember reading about him and
he's not he doesn't even feel like like
there's no russia in his history
no he did like super bad or some like or
like uh i don't know yeah like exactly
whatever that thing about the bachelor
party in vegas
uh number four and five or something
were the ones that he worked
yeah but so he it made me feel really
sad for some reason that
if a person obviously a genius could go
in and just study
and just be uh extreme attention to
detail
they can do a good job it made me think
like
why don't other people do a good job
with this
like about russia like there's so little
about russia
there's so few good films about
the russian side of world war ii of
i mean there's so much interesting evil
and not and beautiful moments in the
history of the 20th century in russia
that feels like there's not many good
films on
from the russians you would expect
something from the russians
well they keep making these propaganda
movies now oh no
unfortunately but yeah no chernobyl was
such a
perfect tv show i think capturing really
well it's not about like even the set
design which was
phenomenal but um just capturing all the
problems that exist now with the country
and like
um focusing on the right things like if
you build the whole country on a lie
that's what's gonna happen and that's
just this very
simple kind of thing
yeah and did you have your dad talked
about it to you
like his thoughts on the experience
he never talks he's this kind of russian
man that just my husband was american
and he
asked him a few times like you know igor
how did you
but why did you say yes or like why did
you decide to go you could have said no
not go to chernobyl why would like a
person like
that's what you do you cannot say no
yeah yeah it's just
it's like a russian way it's the
russians don't talk that much
no there are downsides and upsets for
that
oh yeah that's the truth
you